salut les parents
ravi de vous avoir ici pour le premier
programme de lynette noir de new blanche
merci pouvez vous nous présenter notre
ami oui c'est euh
mr a ouais mike timothy ouais et c'est
mr ecstasy ici
mr ecstasy ouais et tu ressembles à un enfant
bien sûr, alors vous avez décidé de vous installer en
france,
pourquoi avez-vous choisi de passer disons
un mois en france
euh essentiellement parce que je devenais trop
enfermé chez moi à londres j'adore
londres
et je ne voulais pas admettre plus tôt que
j'avais vraiment  un truc contre paris
depuis longtemps
mais c'est probablement l'un des seuls
endroits où
tu peux encore te promener marcher dans la rue
et les gens que
tu connais te respectent et te donnent cet
espace et après avoir été
enfermé pendant longtemps tu exerces
une certaine pression physique
et vous devez juste sortir
et laisser l'air vous frapper à nouveau
et c'est probablement l'endroit idéal pour
cela c'est une belle ville c'est une
ville très romantique
mais écoutez vous vous viviez dans
l'état  s tu as quitté les états pour venir
en angleterre et ensuite tu as quitté l'angleterre pour
venir en france
eh bien je n'ai pas dit que tu avais un problème
eh bien peut être que je suis un peu gitan ou vague
donc je peux me voir
vivre à londres pour un  très très
longtemps mais je pense encore une fois que
vous avez besoin d'un endroit où vous pouvez marcher dans
la rue et sentir que
vous savez vous sentir à l'aise où les gens
vous aiment et ils vous acceptent mais ils
vous donnent votre liberté et votre espace
où restez-vous ici à paris i
je veux dire je veux vous demander de dire votre adresse
parce qu'il y aura beaucoup de
monde devant chez vous mais
quel genre d'endroit de la ville avez-vous
choisi c'est euh
je pense que c'est quelque part autour du bus
ici ouais
comme un joli petit funky  tu sais que
ça va nous restons tous dedans comme
si c'était un peu
comme les hippies hippies viennent ici ouais
nous partageons diverses choses c'est tout à
fait ça va mais je planifie toujours ta vie
toi tu écris du matériel pour ton prochain
album bien tout le tout le  le matériel
est basique  ment écrit c'est fini c'était pratiquement fini il y
a longtemps c'est
juste maintenant
parce que nous sommes sur la route depuis
si longtemps
et j'avais fait d'autres choses en
m'occupant des affaires et des trucs que
vous ne pouvez pas sortir  de ne pas être dans
l'océan pendant longtemps, puis de
revenir directement en vous, de
faire une transition graduelle
et c'est en quelque sorte la raison pour laquelle je suis ici, nous sommes en
quelque sorte venus sous la prémisse de faire un
peu de travail que nous avons fini par faire  merde
tout ce que
vous savez, c'est juste que vous traînez tous les
soirs en voyant des nuages auxquels vous vous accrochez tous les soirs
ouais
en gros tous les deux jours pouve
-vous nous parler de votre prochain album même
si vous ne voulez pas en di
e beaucoup mais juste quelques indic
tions pour le  les gens qui vous aiment
bien je pense à ce que nous avons
accompli
dans le dernier depuis le premier album est une
certaine surprise que
tout le monde se demande à quoi ressemblera le
prochain j'en suis très content
donc si je disais en quelque sorte  vous ce que ça
allait sonner li  ke
ça ne sonnera pas
bien je ne dirai pas comment ça va
sonner ça va être
les rumeurs sont vraies que ce sera un
double um
album double directement ouais c'est pas si
dur de faire un double
album comme s'il y avait un deuxième album
je ne le ferais pas à moins que le matériel ne soit
là, vous savez que je ne le ferais pas,
mais en même temps,
je pense qu'il y a définitivement un
élément voyou dans mon personnage et c'est l'une de
ces choses si vous pouvez vous en sortir
vous savez instantanément instinctivement
que les gens
diront qui diable est cette personne pour faire un
double album qui est le deuxième d'entre eux
et j'aime vraiment faire des choses
qui
énervent les gens et les font en
quelque sorte réévaluer leur genre de technologie tenté
fatigué  opinions je suppose
donc c'est vous vous mettez dans un coin
si vous ne pouvez pas vous en sortir
avec ça les gens disent un mauvais coup
mais si on sort le lapin du
chapeau comme je pense qu'on va le faire
ça va se voir  comme un geste audacieux pour que
vous sachiez que le prince d  décidé d'
acheter un appartement à paris et
vous vous l'avez rencontré parce que nous avons
demandé
la semaine dernière nous avons demandé au
manager de fannie lee à votre sujet quand il a dit que
j'ai dit que vous n'aviez pas un peu
peur de dire la force
il a dit que nous l'aimions beaucoup et que vous avez
déjà rencontré le prince
oui, nous avons donc passé du temps ensemble à
quelques reprises
ouais vous savez que je ne suis pas le genre de
personne qui
euh je ne suis pas le genre de personne qui est  comme une
personne jalouse jalouse il y a des gens que j'envie mais
je ne suis pas une personne jalouse
mais tu sais euh princesse à ma
génération ce que la pierre sournoise était à sa
génération tu sais
et j'ai énormément de
respect pour lui
et dans un  de nombreuses façons je l'aime tu
sais mais
il je pense que si ce n'était pas pour lui,
tu ne saurais pas que mon album est
sorti et surtout en Amérique avec
un
endroit si fermé tu sais où tu sais que les noirs font
ça et  les blancs font ça et c'est
complètement foutu c'est juste qu'on a défié toutes
sortes de um
logisti  cs et si le prince n'était pas
venu avant,
cela aurait été beaucoup plus difficile
pour moi, alors je l'
apprécie vraiment, vous savez qu'il est
impliqué dans la
spiritualité et le sexe, vous deux,
je le regarde comme ça, je veux dire
prendre ces questions  très sérieusement,
vous trouvez que la plupart de la grande musique un
certain
euh mon héritage musical est probablement
égal au rock and roll euh donc
rmb ou quoi que ce soit je ne peux pas dire que l'un
m'a plus influencé que l'autre mais si
vous regardez le
bon genre  de euh chanteurs de black soul, vous
trouverez que la dichotomie entre le
sexe et la spiritualité est toujours un
problème principal au cœur de leur musique
certainement marvin gaye a souffert avec cela
certainement notre vert a souffert avec ce
euh teddy penderground je pense que même
joey lewis
vous  lire le livre sur la
vie de marvin gaye oui le divorce
il y était très impliqué oui ouais et
je veux dire je pense que
toute personne qui sent qu'elle a une
sorte d'appel supérieur
doit trouver un équilibre entre la spiritualité et
la luxure
mais si quelqu'un a déjà fait de l'acide ou
quelque chose comme ça,
je pense que vous devriez commencer à
apprécier le fait que la luxure est
probablement une émotion très ancrée
parce que si ce n'était pas pour la luxure,
je pense que
trop d'entre nous passeraient la plupart de notre
temps  trop loin dans les nuages
nt de réfléchir à la voie du monde au lieu de si
plement s'envoyer en l'air comme toute bonne
personne devrait le faire de temps en te
ps vous aimez les filles françaises vous
tes très intéressé par les jeunes expre
sions agiss
nt pourquoi vous bavardez  Je vais
dormir
non je te dis ça parce que je suis sûr
qu'il dit non parce que tu es passé par là
tu me posais des questions sur le prince vivant
à paris ouais
tu vois la raison pour laquelle je ne veux pas avoir un
appartement à paris c'est parce que je pense  cette
ville n'est peut-être pas assez grande pour moi et le
prince vivant en même temps
ouais, mais au-delà de ça, je veux dire que
je suis jeune et je pense
pour être honnête, vous savez que les gens vont vous savez,
je veux dire que je pense que c'est complètement
chose naturelle normale que si vous êtes vous  ng
et vous rencontrez un certain succès, vous
appréciez l'attention que vous recevez,
je veux dire que j'étais sérieux parce que je suis sûr
que vous voulez être
impliqué dans la réalisation de films, donc je suis
là pour ça, c'est peut-être bien
pour moi  pour traîner des
techniques et des choses comme ça purement
commercial ne vous préoccupez pas de
rien d'autre
mais dans les films dans une entreprise de musique maintenant nous avons
besoin d'un film nous avons besoin d'un clip avec
tout c'est très visuel
comme toujours l'artiste maintenant si intéressant à
cause d'Israël
êtes-vous en contact  avec n'importe quel réalisateur pour
votre prochain clip non
mais j'ai euh l'une des personnes que
j'essaie de voir
quand je viens est roman polanski
et
je veux dire qu'il est tellement au-dessus de ce genre de
choses que je ne lui demanderais jamais vraiment mais
en même temps  le temps que j'aimerais
travailler avec eux ou quelque chose comme
ça tu as un bon feeling avec la
romance
ouais il y en a beaucoup je pense que c'est une
personne charmante et il sait comment
il reste très peu de gens qui savent vraiment
comment faire la fête tu es allé super  rapide à e  e
top et
ne pensez-vous pas que certaines erreurs ont été commises
comme si vous saviez que des erreurs ont été
commises mais je pense que si j'avais spécialement
avec les médias je pense parce que vous ne
pensez pas que
vous devriez mon erreur  Je n'ai pas
surestimé les médias, c'était
définitivement mon erreur, ce n'était pas quelque chose que
vous savez, je pensais vraiment que
vous le saviez parce que je lis les journaux et
tout,
et surtout en Angleterre et en Amérique,
vous voyez trop souvent des
artistes, vous savez qu'ils disent que je ne le fais pas.  je ne veux
pas parler de sexe ou de religion ou de
politique ou
pas de la maison de disques je veux seulement
parler de mon disque
et je dois dire que c'est le meilleur
disque que j'ai jamais fait j'en suis très
content tu sais et j'ai pensé  eh bien
ils se plaignent toujours que personne
peut-être que tu étais
un grand masque non ouais bien sûr j'étais une grande
gueule mais
j'essayais j'étais peut-être que tes disques
étaient suffisants pour te faire connaître et
tu ne l'as pas fait
je n'étais pas  Je n'allais pas prendre cette chance, je
n'allais pas prendre cette chance ouais
parce qu'il
y a trop de gens avec beaucoup
de talent et
comment puis-je savoir au fond de moi que la
seule raison pour laquelle mon album
n'a pas eu beaucoup de succès par rapport à
quelqu'un d'autre était
que ma façon de parler a capté l'attention des gens
et cet album était  un groupe d'
enfants
auxquels j'avais donné naissance et en tant que
mère de ces enfants, je ne
laisserais pas au hasard
que quelqu'un puisse entrer dans le
magasin et le laisser passer
pour l'album de quelqu'un d'autre, donc
j'allais tout faire à l'intérieur  mon pouvoir
de capter votre attention pour que
vous soyez obligé d'écouter ce que
cette grande vous savez cet album cette grande
gueule parle
vous savez je ne voulais pas dire la moitié de ce que j'ai
dit mais en même temps ce que j'ai fait  Je ne
sais pas qu'il y avait des problèmes à propos de votre
légende et les gens disent qu'il
dit que
vous le savez bien, mais avec la légende
pour être honnête avec vous,
95 de cela était vrai que les choses étaient
exagérées, quelques choses étaient
exagérées
mais jamais  ything qui est vrai et maintenant vous avez
décidé de parler
votre cœur normalement euh
ce que je faisais le plus la chose était
50 de ce que je disais
sincèrement et les 50 autres
étaient essentiellement des conneries vous savez mais
c'est les artistes de l'art ont la
réalité ont  des conneries tu sais si tu es
un grand artiste c'est surtout des conneries
toi tu penses que tu es un grand artiste non
j'essaie je veux être une grande
célébrité
et je pense que si je ne pensais pas que peut-être qu'il
n'y avait pas de potentiel  peut-être que je
ne me pousserais pas si fort, mais vous
savez que le
temps vous le dira, nous avons quelqu'un
comme prince
et prince a 10 albums et peut-être 12
ans
pour que nous regardions et disions oui c'est le
grand artiste dont je pense avoir besoin en
même temps est  il y a une question que je
ne t'ai posée nulle part en moi pour te demander
euh pourquoi est-ce si difficile de se droguer dans
cette ville
bleue